fishermen on the pier outside mali's
bustling Fish Market their boats tied up
after unloading the latest catch after
tourism this is the main industry in the
Maldives a nation spread over More Than
A Thousand Islands
just down the road the Coast Guard here
in a temporary dock soon they'll be in a
new Harbor built by the Indian
government to be trained by the Indian
coast guard based in the Maldives
that says one of the presidential
candidates is unacceptable
so what they have done is they've bribed
bribed our politicians and they have
made an inroad into more leaves
thus keeping their troops here that's
where the red lines draw
I love India I don't want their troops
here
under the current Administration India
has committed considerable resources to
the Maldives the new bridge connecting
Malay to several other islands is under
construction financed by the Indian
government
that commitment and geography makes
economic and security cooperation with
India a Natural Choice says the defense
minister of course India is much closer
they are in the neighborhood and from
time immemorial we have always had even
president Yamin had an India first
policy because we are so close as
neighbors and we have always depended on
each other
the opposition says that help is
available elsewhere without the need to
make concessions on security
until 2018 when it was in power China
was seen as the major overseas partner
to the Maldives the China friendship
Bridge linking the capital Mali to the
airport has increased visitor capacity
and made life much easier for people
moving between the islands
but that project and other developments
have saddled the government with
considerable debts one of the most
pressing problems for the new president
is how to handle Rising interest rates
and payments due in 2026.
the problem for the Maldives is that to
undertake any kind of major
infrastructure project be it transport
Communications or sanitation you need
huge amounts of money and expertise and
for that it helps to have big and
powerful friends
Tony Chang Al Jazeera Mali
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera